cherry tellement mal à leur tour après
ce week end j'espère que vous allez bien
richir il on est confiné dans qu'est ce
qu'on fait on fait que manger tout ça un
bon bah j'espère que ça va bien pour
vous j'ai plein de trucs à vous lire
qu'est ce que je vois après trois
divorces et trois enfants
il remet ça benjamin castaldi aurore est
enceinte donc sa femme est enceinte sa
femme attend un heureux des veines de
même moment donc on peut l'annoncer ou
est ce que c'est des conneries ou est-ce
qu'on doit de rien dire ou es ce que les
gens aiment ça c'est terrible
si rim offrir aux jouets fait-il que tu
le sais depuis un moment et tu n'as rien
dit donc bravo à toi tu y arrives à te
répudie ça peut faire un petit coup à
l'antenne du l'a pas fait donc ne
discuteraient qu'avec bien
alors est-ce que tu as choisi le parrain
de ton fils est ce que le jeu est posée
je vais proposer des noms est-ce que ça
fait jean michel maire non pas possible
matthieu delormeau non non non non non
non non non non non je veux quelqu'un me
gueguen solide personnes et donc je t'ai
choisi
non vraiment bah oui je sais bien que je
suis je t'ai choisi comme parrain bien
sûr donc c'était pas toi mais on sait
pas une vanne je suis vraiment je serais
vraiment le parrain de son fils je
m'excuse je te laisse te les demandes et
orange ii remonte à l'antenne mais
brasles à l'appel pour voir si tout le
monde est là naulleau et les ados
présents verdez des rêves est présent
benjamin castaldi présent frère sur la
tête de ma mère je t'adore
mes frères on dirait que ça fait onze
ans que tu es en confinement
[Rires]
mais est ce que je me disais que tout le
monde pensait détail a été indûment
franchement magnifique merci d'ailleurs
on à jean pierre pernaut qui est avec
nous aussi ça c'est magnifique pour nous
parce que c'est vrai que jean pierre
on est très heureux de le voir comment
sa robe argentée 1 mais moi je suis en
pleine forme je fais la queue et les
maisons les génial et je te trouve très
d'enfants restent confinés mon joker
comme tout le monde va là parce que toi
tu peux faire passer les messages aux
français il est écouté et atteignent
bois qui porte vraiment eu leur disent
de rester chez eux
c'est le message que j'ai c'est de
passer tous les jours d'avoir j'essaie
de montrer l'exemple
pourquoi moi je suis là et jacques
legros est à l'emploi c'est tout
simplement parce que ben j'ai eu
quelques petits problèmes de santé comme
chacun sait il y avait une médiation
donc je pense que si je croisais cette
motion un virus il aimerait beaucoup de
boufflers donc je préfère rester à la
maison avec attali qui est là qui vous
fait pas le choix il a pas de soi je
vais continuer
ils ont aussi riehl on t'aime le lâche
pas on en a besoin on en a besoin
c'est quoi ta reid un stade tout va tout
va tu te regarde
bonjour à tous gérard michel les côtes
d'armor champions 2005-2006 de bingo sur
foot y allant moins bon c'est très sain
jour 4 de confinement on nous prend au
mot et qu'on le gouvernement s'ils n'ont
rien entrepris de rock de racheter tous
les mac donald d'accord pourra faire des
restaurants italiens à melon tegra fait
pour tout le monde comme ça mc donald
et pourquoi que le gouvernement français
il est de mèche et c'est là que
l'information je vais vous donner elle
est tombée par terre
d'accord mais je les vérifier pour les
regarder sur internet c'est la vérité
mcgraw-hill chinois ouais je suis fou de
ce personnel ferruccio perso mais je te
promets une chose dès qu'on sort de
confinement mon frère je viens avec ses
personnages mais je te jure frère c'est
moi tout une émission haute et on a fêté
comme personnage tu donnes ton avis sur
les émissions comme ça et on fait d'
archaïque aucun problème je t'aime à m
tu sais que je t'aime fort
olala il est là mon jean pierre il est
tout bronzé les manifs année aucune
ébauche celui-ci qui les mots de moulins
1 5-1 charges exceptionnelles c'est un
petit chat je me suis fait plaisir
jean-pierre j'ai pensé que ça pouvait le
faire alors on ça fait 15 jours que
j'embrasse pas fan de 13 jours je compte
je compte
oui c'était vendredi a pas de cela il ya
des ya dix jours on attend vendredi pour
s'embrasser parce qu'il faudra être
prudent quand même c'est fou ça ah ouais
vous sophie cost
maj embrasse personne lui tout seul en
fait non ah ouais ouais vous est membre
ouais vous aimez embrassement vous
aimons brassens qu'il ya des femmes qui
aiment pas trop angoissé à moi j'étais
championne de roulage de pelle
ile-de-france en 88
j'ai un t-shirt d'ailleurs assez votre
kif
j'aurais voulu chercher j'adore j'adore
c'est tout c'est tout passe par là en
fait au départ fait tout de suite on a
que tu fous de ça qui va jouer avec nous
il y aura 100 ans en 1120 euros un
casque audio le dernier album des tribal
king tribal king rappeler est un pèse
personne et un kilo de kiwis bonjour ma
chérie comment ça va comment tu
t'appelles et ma chérie on va jouer tu
va choisir une boîte à la fin d'accord
tu vas en d'éliminer cette et la
dernière qui restera ce sera ta boîte
tacoma chéri d'amour
à numéro 2 la numéro numéro deux et dans
la numéro deux tu viens de perdre
tu viens de perdre ma chérie le casque
audio à habas donner mon avis g saint
louis chalois pas lui ça lui je t'en
supplie pas lui ah on a le banquier
merzouk albers blanchard qui est arrivé
bonjour mr donc aujourd'hui
[Rires]
alors qu'est ce que tu vas a saisi les
designer's merde tu sais pourquoi
toulouse à peine où tu sais pas du tout
bien sûr à cause du coup fumant je peux
pas me couper les cheveux
les aides
c'est où 5000 ou 1000 euros
[Musique]
qui mêleront
c'est bien et on va vérifier quand même
regarder dans dans la 3 dans la
troisième dans la 3d les j'aimerais que
chacun fasse une petite danse contre un
mur voilà ce soir on va démarrer travail
celui qui est le meilleur danseur c'est
gilles verdez à l'auto on peut pas voir
ta gueule
[Musique]
voilà merci bon bah c'est qu'elle va
lasser les nuls a dit castaldi à toi
voilà il est voilà qui attend siège on
voit pas mais c'est pas grave ça lui
ferait que les normes et de budo s'en
fout que dans mes poireaux quelques mois
[Musique]
elle a des choses bravo sophy pas si
laurence à thouars chez plutôt pour la
porter
c'est une logique d'une petite danse non
vas-y vas-y vas-y tu t'inquiètes
attendent des politiques qu'ils dansent
en bannière derrière dans sa classe
c'est une petite danse holla holla mais
ça donne quoi bon voilà donc les mecs
elle est ce qu est ce que vous avez déjà
fait l'amour sur une aire d'autoroute où
laurent c'est donc moi si ce n'est
absolument de west qu'elle n'a pas fait
ça alors c'est pas vrai alors c'est mal
connaître mais qui veulent soit pas ce
que je vais dire et qui dit ça parce que
ça fait des mois qu'ils essayent j'ai
toujours dit non alors il
ça tombe ça tombe ça